Did Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu insult and mock Jesus and
declare that evil is more powerful than
good and say that following Satan is
better than following Jesus?
I don't know, because I keep hearing
that these Netanyahu videos I'm supposed
to be enraged about are just AI.
How can I get mad at a guy who's not
actually there?
What's weird is that the accounts
telling me that Netanyahu is the
Antichrist for what he said about Jesus
are the same accounts telling me that
Netanyahu is no longer with us and that
the videos of him are all fake.
Come on, Groypers, pick a struggle.
But let's see what people are saying
about AI BB's remarks about Jesus.
The post lots of people are sharing is
from Disclose TV, big channel, 1.6
million followers. The clip they shared
had 27.7 million views when I took the
screenshot. It says,
"Now, Netanyahu, Jesus Christ has no
advantage over Genghis Khan, because if
you are strong enough, ruthless enough,
powerful enough, evil will overcome
good."
BRICS News posted, "Just in, Israeli
Prime Minister Netanyahu says, Jesus
Christ has no advantage over Genghis
Khan.
If you are strong enough, ruthless
enough, and powerful enough, evil will
overcome good."
Another big channel, BRICS News has 1.9
million followers. They included an
18-second clip of what Netanyahu said.
It got 2.3 million views on their page.
Let's watch.
Unfortunately and unhappily,
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan.
Because if you are strong enough,
ruthless enough, powerful enough,
evil will overcome good.
Aggression will overcome moderation.
Wow, judging from that 18-second clip,
sounds like he did say it. No wonder
people are flipping out.
Jenny Robinson, I still honestly cannot
believe he had the audacity to actually
say this.
Hillbilly things, you are not a
Christian if you support this man and
his demon state Israel. Yeah, yahoo.
Being libertarian, how did American
Christians get brainwashed into
supporting wholeheartedly a dude that
preaches the exact opposite of their
faith?
Subhoor Ahmed, if you are a devil
worshiper, Genghis Khan is a better role
model than Jesus. Satan Yahoo is being
honest for once.
Fearless Modad, how hard is it to
identify an enemy of your morality?
Netanyahu is arguing against Christian
morality and is saying that if he
believes it right, he should be allowed
to act worse than Genghis Khan. This is
the path to hell.
My goodness, pretty rough.
But,
I'm glad I have a bunch of people on X
telling me what Netanyahu said and what
he meant.
Hey, wait a minute.
I just remembered that people lied to me
all the time on X. Just a few weeks ago,
I saw dozens of posts assuring me that
Iranian missiles had sunk the USS
Abraham Lincoln, an aircraft carrier.
But, it turned out not to be true.
Some of the same accounts that told me
the USS Abraham Lincoln had been sunk
are now telling me that Netanyahu said
Genghis Khan is greater than Jesus. And
that Netanyahu is no longer with us, so
he couldn't have said anything.
Maybe instead of mindlessly accepting
what people are claiming on X, I should
spend a few minutes making sure they're
right.
Let's see if we can get to the bottom of
this, not in the Zot sense.
The clips that people are sharing are
from Netanyahu's March 19th press
conference, where he was defending the
war in Iran. He lays out the three goals
of the US and Israel.
Our goals
are three.
One,
removing the nuclear threat.
Second, removing the ballistic missile
threat, and removing both of these
threats before they're buried deep
underground and become immune from
aerial attack.
And third, this means creating the
conditions for the Iranian people
to grasp their freedom, to control their
destiny.
Why does he think these goals are
reasonable? Because the current Iranian
leaders have made it crystal clear for
decades what their goals are.
This regime, as I said in the beginning
of my remarks, is chanting "Death to
Israel, death to America."
But they say Israel is only the small
Satan standing in their way.
The great Satan is the United States of
America.
And these ideological fanatics, these
lunatics, they find their raison d'être,
their reason for being,
is wiping out Western civilization and
America that leads it.
They have uh
claimed the lives.
They've maimed and wounded thousands of
Americans in Iraq and Afghanistan.
They killed the American Marines in
Beirut. They bombed your embassies. They
tried to assassinate the American
president, Donald Trump, not once, but
twice.
Just imagine what they would do, what
they're capable of doing.
If these lunatics had nuclear weapons
and the means to deliver them to every
American city and every European city
and everywhere around the globe.
This is a danger for the entire world.
It's certainly a danger for Israel. It's
certainly a danger for America. We see
eye to eye on that.
Netanyahu then points out that when
you're dealing with people who want to
destroy you, it's better to act than to
sit back and wait while they build up
their arsenals.
What do you think would have happened
if America did not act now?
Just imagine what would have happened.
In a few months time, no more than a
year,
Khamenei, still alive,
would have ordered the beginnings of the
new
uh nuclear program
and the reconstructed ballistic missile
program to move underground.
Now, it'll take them a little time,
maybe a few years,
but you can't reach those programs and
they develop intercontinental ballistic
missiles, okay?
That means missiles that can hit Chicago
and New York and Florida
and Texas and California.
Oh, but they don't have it yet. That's
what people said. Right, let's wait.
So you'd sit back and you say, well,
it's not going to happen in the next
Thursday, so let's not act.
I tell you that
there's enormous risk in not acting,
much greater risk than acting. Many
quotes Winston Churchill on democracies
falling asleep.
Churchill said
that democracies suffer from the slumber
of democracies, as he called it, and
they only wake up, he said, they may
wake up only when they hear the
the gong, the jarring gong of danger, is
the way he put it.
Well,
you're hearing the gong the the jarring
gong of danger.
The jarring gong of danger is Iran gets
nuclear weapons and ballistic missiles.
That's not a jarring gong. That is an
apocalypse. Don't let it happen. And now
we get to the part that was so
incredibly upsetting to people who were
really looking for something to get
upset about.
Netanyahu says that it's naive to think
that we don't have to act to stop evil
regimes hell-bent on destroying us.
Some people apparently think that evil
regimes will fail simply because they're
evil. So, good people just need to keep
being good and things will work out even
if all the good people sit back and do
nothing.
You know, if people want to be naive
that they don't see the kind of world
we're living in.
In this world
it's not enough to be moral.
It's not enough to be just.
It's not enough to be right.
To support his point, he cites the 20th
century historian Will Durant.
One of Durant's lessons of history was
that evil regimes are stopped by force,
not by their enemies being good or
right.
Uh one of the greatest uh
writers of the 20th century, someone
that I admire a lot, was the historian
Will Durant.
Now, he wrote
many volumes. I read most of them.
He also wrote the lessons of history.
Very brief, 100-page book
uh in which he said
well, history [snorts] proves
that
unfortunately and unhappily
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan.
You see there?
Bibi Netanyahu said that Jesus is no
better than Genghis Khan.
Yeah, I said Genghis, not Jenghis.
Why? Because I learned the correct
pronunciation from the greatest history
presentation of all time.
Please welcome the very excellent
barbarian, MR. GENGHIS KHAN.
>> [cheering and applause]
>> WILL DURANT WAS ACTUALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENT point from the one Netanyahu
was making. Durant was an atheist. He
didn't believe in a personal God, but he
considered himself a kind of Christian
in that he believed in following the
moral teachings of Jesus. He really
liked Jesus, but he rejected the
supernatural elements of the story.
Durant thought that history doesn't
support belief in God because battles
are usually won by whichever side is
more powerful, not by whichever side is
more ethical or right. This is from
chapter 7, religion and history.
Does history support a belief in God? If
by God, we mean not the creative
vitality of nature, but a supreme being,
intelligent and benevolent, the answer
must be a reluctant negative. Like other
departments of biology, history remains
at bottom, not in the Zoot Suit sense, a
natural selection of the fittest
individuals and groups in a struggle
wherein goodness receives no favors,
misfortunes abound, and the final test
is the ability to survive.
Add to the crimes, wars, and cruelties
of man, the earthquakes, storms,
tornadoes, pestilences, tidal waves, and
other acts of God that periodically
desolate human and animal life, and the
total evidence suggests either a blind
or an impartial fatality with incidental
and apparently haphazard scenes to which
we subjectively ascribe order, splendor,
beauty, or sublimity.
If history supports any theology, this
would be a dualism like the Zoroastrian
or Manichaean, a good spirit and an evil
spirit battling for control of the
universe and men's souls. These faiths
and Christianity, which is essentially
Manichaean, assured their followers that
the good spirit would win in the end.
But of this consummation, history offers
no guarantee.
Nature and history do not agree with our
conceptions of good and bad. They define
good as that which survives and bad as
that which goes under. And the universe
has no prejudice in favor of Christ as
against Genghis Khan.
The universe has no prejudice in favor
of Christ as against Genghis Khan.
What is Durant talking about?
He's offering a historical version of
what's called the problem of evil. If
God exists, why is there so much
suffering in the world? Why do bad
things happen even to the best people?
For the historical version, it's
basically in terms of historical
relevance and impact, history doesn't
care whether the Babylonians were
morally better than the people they
conquered. It only cares that the empire
was powerful enough to make its mark on
history for a while.
Same with the Persians and the Greeks
and the Romans and so on.
Durant uses Jesus as an example of
someone who's supremely moral and he
uses Genghis Khan as an example of an
evil tyrant.
He notes that the universe doesn't
somehow say, "Wow, Jesus is really good.
So I'm going to make sure nothing bad
happens to him. But Genghis Khan, what
an evil scumbag. I'm going to stop him
before he kills tons of people."
The universe doesn't seem to care,
according to Durant.
In chapter 11, History and War, Durant
applies this to military history. He
writes,
"In every century, the generals and the
rulers, with rare exceptions like Ashoka
and Augustus, have smiled at the
philosophers' timid dislike of war. In
the military interpretation of history,
war is the final arbiter and is accepted
as natural and necessary by all but
cowards and simpletons. What but the
victory of Charles Martel at Tours in
732 kept France and Spain from becoming
What would have happened to our classic
heritage if it had not been protected by
arms against Mongol and Tatar invasions?
We laugh at generals who die in bed,
forgetting that they are more valuable
alive than dead, but we build statues to
them when they turn back a Hitler or a
Genghis Khan.
"It is pitiful," says the general, "that
so many young men die in battle, but
more of them die in automobile accidents
than in war, and many of them riot and
rot for lack of discipline. They need an
outlet for their combativeness, their
adventurousness, their weariness with
prosaic routine.
If they must die sooner or later, why
not let them die for their country in
the anesthesia of battle and the aura of
glory?
Even a philosopher, if he knows history,
will admit that a long peace may fatally
weaken the martial muscles of a nation.
In the present inadequacy of
international law and sentiment, a
nation must be ready at any moment to
defend itself. And when its essential
interests are involved, it must be
allowed to use any means it considers
necessary to its survival. The Ten
Commandments must be silent when
self-preservation is at stake.
What's he saying? He's saying that the
battle doesn't seem to be decided based
on who's the most moral, the most
loving, the kindest, the most generous,
or the most religious. Battles are
usually won by the side with the
superior military, whether that military
is run by a pious king or an evil
dictator.
That's Durant's point. Netanyahu goes in
a different direction. He takes the
lesson of history, namely, when it comes
to battles, history doesn't care which
side is morally better, it only cares
which side wins. And he concludes that
being good by itself isn't what stops an
evil regime.
In this world,
it's not enough to be moral.
It's not enough to be just. It's not
enough to be right.
Unfortunately and unhappily,
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan.
Because if you are strong enough,
ruthless enough, powerful enough,
evil will overcome good.
Aggression will overcome moderation.
Being good or right isn't enough. You
have to act to stop an evil regime. So,
Netanyahu and Durant both use Jesus as
an example of someone who is supremely
moral, and Genghis Khan as an example of
an evil tyrant. Does being good stop the
evil tyrant? No. You can dedicate your
life to feeding the poor and healing the
sick, that doesn't stop the evil regime.
An invading army led by an evil tyrant
won't be turned back by you going to
church. That doesn't stop the invasion.
So, you have no choice.
If you look at the world as it is today,
you have to be blind not to see
that the democracies led by the
[clears throat] United States
have to reassert their will to defend
themselves
and to oppose their enemies in time
while there's still time
before the jarring gong of danger
wakes them up and wakes them up too
late. This is where we are now. From the
perspective of history, what does stop
an evil regime from destroying you?
Being strong and acting.
We have to be strong. We have to be
armed. We have to be more powerful than
the barbarians or they will not be
merely at the gate, they'll crash our
gates and destroy our societies.
So, Netanyahu is making the exact same
point as the quote that's mistakenly
attributed to Edmund Burke, "The only
thing necessary for the triumph of evil
is for good men to do nothing."
When people post that quote on X, "The
only thing necessary for the triumph of
evil is for good men to do nothing,"
I never see anyone objecting.
Why?
Because it's obvious. If a terrorist
decides to blow up a bus and no one
stops him, it doesn't matter if the
people on the bus are the nicest people
in the world.
No one stops the terrorist, bad things
happen.
What stopped the Muslim invasion of
Europe?
Armies. What stopped the Germans during
World War II?
Armies.
Being right, being good, being just,
none of it stops an evil regime without
actually doing something.
This shouldn't be controversial at all.
So, why has it suddenly become
controversial to say that you have to
stand up to bad people in order to keep
them from doing bad things?
Because Netanyahu said it. And anything
he says must be wrong because a bunch of
people don't like him.
Netanyahu could say tomorrow that 2 + 2
= 4 and you would instantly get a war on
mathematics from groupers and Muslims
and online orthobros and Candace Owens.
Be honest.
Whether you agree with Netanyahu or not,
was he insulting Jesus?
No, he was using Jesus as an example of
a supremely moral person and pointing
out that this supreme morality wouldn't
stop an evil person unless it was
combined with some sort of action.
Was Netanyahu saying might makes right?
No, he was saying that goodness needs to
be combined with strength in order to
stop an evil regime.
Do you disagree?
Do you believe that if an evil dictator
is coming to destroy your civilization,
you don't need to stop him as long as
you're good?
Let's read a few more reactions to the
Netanyahu clip.
He is flat-out telling us to choose
Satan over Jesus Christ.
Is that what you heard?
I never thought I'd live to hear the
devil speaking on Earth, but here's the
proof. Notice to all Christian Zionists
who validate this kind of argument.
Netanyahu has just disdained Jesus
Christ and justifies the brutality of
Genghis Khan.
Did you hear Netanyahu justify the
brutality of Genghis Khan?
Or did you hear him say that if you want
to stop someone like Genghis Khan, you
have to, oh, I don't know,
stop him?
Netanyahu went full edge lord. Jesus
Christ has no advantage over Genghis
Khan because if you are strong enough,
ruthless enough, powerful enough, evil
will overcome good. Bro, that's not a
flex. That's a facepalm on steroids.
Israel's already fighting the global
optics war and the PM decides to drop
might makes right. Jesus who? In the
middle of it?
PR team must be screaming into pillows
right now.
He didn't say might makes right. He
basically said right needs might so that
it can protect itself when the wrong
comes to destroy it.
Denigrating the Christian God while
relying on military support from a
Christian country is crazy.
Breaking video. Jesus Christ has no
advantage over Genghis Khan. Netanyahu
says Genghis Khan would defeat Jesus
Christ because he's more powerful. So
therefore, the democracies led by the US
have no choice but to join their fight
against Iran.
Father Martin Navarro, a Catholic
priest,
Bibi justifies the Holocaust.
In this short clip, Netanyahu insults
Christians and Jesus Christ, asserts
there's no purpose in being a good
person, says we have no choice but to
fight Israel's wars, subtly threatens us
if we don't.
We're in the midst of the worst
anti-Semitism crisis in modern history
and the Israeli Prime Minister is out
here saying Jesus is nothing compared to
a mass-murdering rapist and evil is
better than good.
The resurrection proved that evil does
not overcome good.
Well, now you're talking about the
resurrection and some sort of ultimate
victory over evil, not about evil
regimes.
Did the resurrection keep evil regimes
from rising to power?
Did it?
Do governments no longer need to defend
their citizens from evil regimes because
of the resurrection?
Is that your theology?
This quote by Netanyahu is offensive on
multiple levels. It not only compares
Jesus to Genghis Khan, but also suggests
that the way of Jesus is naive, while a
ruthless might makes right approach,
marked by relentless aggression, is what
ultimately allows good to overcome evil.
Netanyahu and his Christian Zionist
supporters are making a mockery of the
ethics of Jesus. That is the true
offense.
They can't hide their hatred of Jesus,
peace be upon him.
For a man so reliant on goodwill of
Christians in the United States,
Netanyahu's open disdain for Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, is
remarkable. His unbridled praise for
Genghis Khan, the worst slaughterer our
region has ever seen, also fits with his
current status as a wanted war criminal.
Terrifying exposure of the Zionist
mindset. Netanyahu literally quotes a
historian saying, "Jesus Christ has no
advantage over Genghis Khan to justify
absolute ruthlessness and mass
violence." He is openly declaring that
might makes right.
With their listening and comprehension
skills, I wonder how any of these people
made it past fourth grade.
But it's really not about listening
comprehension, is it?
We've gotten to a point where
if you don't like someone,
it's okay to lie about the person in
order to stir up more hostility and
resentment.
And the really creepy part is that
if you correct the lie, if you say,
"Well, let's take a closer look at the
context."
you're the bad one.
And I know this because whenever someone
says, "He just mocked Jesus." And I say,
"No, he didn't." people say, "Oh my
goodness, David, why are you simping for
Israel?"
So, lying is now good and exposing lies
is now bad.
And these are the people screaming about
morality and supposedly defending Jesus.
Weird times. Now, just to be clear, I
don't know a whole lot about Netanyahu,
what kind of person he is behind the
scenes.
I think he's a good speaker, I think he
has a cool voice, I mostly know what
I've heard in some speeches. So, for all
I know, he could be a total dirtbag.
But, was he insulting Jesus and mocking
Christians?
No.
And if you say he was after everything
we just saw,
don't expect me to trust you
because you're either too biased or too
deceptive or too quick to believe any
post you see on X
to be an accurate source of information
about someone you don't like.
Who told you that? Who told you that?
Who told you that?
It is not finality.
Who told you that? Who told you that?
Who told you that?
It is not [music] finality. This is a
power of religion. There is a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?